[Music]
so when we're asking the question what's
going wrong with medical practice
decisions about medical practice are
based on stuff that's happening in the
background and there I think we should
focus on three important low sigh I call
these the 3 R's regulation research and
really bad pharmaceutical companies so
the medical research is malleable the
best trials and meta analyses can be
bent to the will of the scientists that
are performing them I had this nice
quote from an insider epidemiologist at
the FDA this is David Graham he's he's
been one of he's one of my heroes
because he's a kind of insider that
fights the good fight here's what Graham
says about the FDA his employer the FDA
is inherently biased in favor of the
pharmaceutical industry it views
industry at it as its clients whose
interests it must represent and advance
it views its primary mission as
approving as many drugs as it can
regardless of whether the drugs are safe
or need it I kind of wonder what his
boss said about that but but that's
David Graham an insider the FDA so
research regulation and then we've heard
about really bad pharmaceutical industry
so David you do you think that better
regulation could help or is that just
you know sticking plaster over a deeper
problem two big problems I think our
instinctive response to these things is
to turn to regulation it probably
shouldn't be the key thing that I'm
trying to say to you is you need to
trust yourselves if you're on a pill and
something's happening you need to listen
to yourself there are no father figures
out there who are going to put things
right particularly the regulator's FDA
and NHRA in this country don't regulate
medicine don't regulate doctors they
regulate the wording of adverts and this
is why David Graham is a little naive it
seems to me if he's saying the kinds of
things you say and I actually know David
Graham but and he's a Christian
born-again Christian who's got strong
ethics nobody FDA isn't about that it's
about the wording of adverts the system
was put in place following a horrific
tragedy the Tollan amide tragedy and
this is what governs the practice of
medicine today
and we're before regulation was about
making sure medicines are safe they
switched it to making sure medicines
were efficacious effective they thought
this is going to be a contribution to
safety if the pharmaceutical industry
was forced to show the drugs work well
that will be a little bit safer than
having drugs out there which don't work
okay but not your fact the premium is we
end up with a premium on efficacy it's a
bit like the situation where I mean
nowhere else do we talk about effective
roads or effective cars we talk about
things being safe I mean there's a few
men who like to drive fat fast cars but
for the most part the issue with cars is
all about trying to keep them safe this
is what people are concerned about
yeshuaa planed if you get on a plane
going to New York okay you're not
interested in the most effective plane
does it get to New York 15 minutes
earlier than the other plane I might get
that gets there a hundred percent of the
time you'll go for the one that gets
there a hundred percent of the time if
you invest in the stock market nobody's
there trying to make sure the stock
market is effective they're trying to
ensure that things are as transparent as
we can so that you you know what you're
doing and you're as it were safe instead
we've got this premium on effectiveness
which is leading to people being put on
tons of different drugs with no regard
for whether you're actually being kept
safe or not so but it doesn't presumably
have to be an either/or situation I mean
you can it seems to me you could you can
test for both of those things well in
achill trials safety and efficacy well
no no you can't you can only test one
thing in a clinical trial you may keep
an eye on a bunch of other things that
are happening but you cannot test a drug
just a hundred things and the clinical
trial is all about hypnotizing the
investigator to look on what at what's
called the primary outcome even that is
commonly falsified but the 99 other
things that happened to you on appeal
are not being looked at there may be
occasional hints that this SSRI is gonna
wipe out your sex life and all but not
in fact the clinical trial won't give
you good data on this so our cities are
I mean the biggest problem we've got
here is your doctor used to see you and
used to listen to you they don't because
just look at the computer screen that
has the evidence on it about what this
drug does and nothing about its safety
profile and that's the problem we've got
that's what we've got to try and reverse
and regulation is not going to reverse
that for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you